theatrics behave yourself he presided
over parliament for a decade i've got
very much more experience of these
matters lived within its walls
and now he is banished from the
institution he loves
for bullying an independent panel upheld
21 allegations concluding the respondent
has been a serial bully like many
bullies he had those whom he favored and
those whom he made victims
these three complainants were victims
his evidence in the investigations the
findings of the commissioner and his
submissions to us show also that the
respondent has been a serial liar avoid
the thrust of these allies within hours
john burko hit back no well you're just
reading from the report which of course
sarah you're absolutely entitled to do
but what i'm saying to you
yes and if you'd be kind enough to allow
me to reply i will
thank you he was speaking from the
offices of his pr advisors who have
previously acted for disgraced mps owen
patterson and charlie elfic there is no
independent evidence whatsoever to
suggest that i did what i did was
persist with my report okay i did not
what i'm saying to you is i did not
breach the behavior code i did not ask
you about your shout out i'm asking mr
burke if in a decade you ever lost your
temper people get annoyed from time to
time if you're challenging me as to when
i lost my temper perhaps you'd be kind
enough to say when that was as far as i
recall i most certainly didn't
robert rogers served the commons for 42
years he resigned as its clerk and chief
executive after being repeatedly bullied
by john burko
ranting
bad language
shouting
invading my personal space
humiliation
mimicry
where do you stop
what does that feel like
it feels
incredibly stressful and unpleasant
david leakey made one of the first
complaints
he has shown no sign of redemption or
contrition or apology and if that
continues to be the case then he has no
place in public life
for a man famed for his bombast and
bravado this damning report may now
force what always seemed impossible
john burko's silence joe pike sky news
westminster